これはフリスクベルに自慢されます200,000
結婚チャー肇社長とまっ
あればね授業にはまっているわけなんですけどもう勇気をどういうゲームかというと
相手のライフポイント8000ポイント削ったら勝つというゲームでございます
他にもいろんな勝ち方があるんですけれども基本的には8000ポイント長いけど
ケーキして者のみしかなかったんですけど
アイポイント100万でやったらどうなるのかなと思いますね気になんないでもいつも
発生ですが100何て言うんだよ
どんな世界が張ってノールだぞ確実に1キルがない
眼球内の一発で殺すのはほぼ無理ですそれで今回ちょっとこの2人で1件ありぽいと
100万円で湯気をやってみようと思います特別ルールとしてですね以上できた車に
なると負けなんですけどもうね
今度100万であるとデッキが出ればいいんだけどが当たり前なんで敵機が0前になっ
たら
墓地のカードをビッキーに戻してもう1回やることにします
これ特別グルって100万のライフを0になる瞬間まで行ってどれだけかかるかという
基本的に特殊勝利がないという戦いで1回遊戯王をやってみようと思います恋愛道
よろしくお願いますお願いします
ブービーけっこうすごい攻撃力高いので殴りあうかなぁ顕在化ある日悪魔んぬー
びっくりすると言うよ
全部そっちてくうん
yeah
早速酒と最高はいどうぞ
同簡裁ということだねあーください発動者がまさしくのはこれから99万9000
200になりました
medias を通常者からどうぞ
パンフレットフェスソロ2回目位
先日た活動いくつがデッキ15枚を紹介します
グラ飲んでグラフの特徴かはいまとめじゃ
6全国1位
正木ドライバーだった中19万5000円です
通常召喚
でカミセン手間だけのライフへとか反応になりますマルニだよこれでかいよこれですよ
48番ができたぞで台座いきますが
ペンジュラム召喚入っ
ことえマッチます度線がー
これを色柄がたハックになるんだよねバディだよね
でかいでかいうわぁああ絶景な
早いぞこれけっこうでこいつは効果があるので2者間に変えてきましたーい
下羽あり15まで一貫して手掛けるあうそ
あれ
あああああいいいいいいいい
きゅあきゅん
dj
以前偶然
ドアを中盤まできた十分持った
塗りやすいございます
2ぐらいポイントになったよ6875ではドロメデストロ
楽しいのか人はまあまあ
はいうわぁここでか
today
やる気あおにゃれねーよ座薬うっ
受けましょうはぁまずいでしょ
はい
じゅやーん
ちょっこっと来なさいねもうちょっとなんかに時間のかかるかなと思ったんですけど
青田買いだというのはないですけど
などと上にロックされてあげもできなかったからかなりいい
5だと思うんですこれは第4100万ひょっとこロペス4時間48分53秒54以来
ポイントが僕がゼロでまた木登りが10万球
9602.5神の宣告を使ってバルギーが何回が起きたのでそういう2点がついて
しまいました
次は
1億でやろう
me
いっ